nous n'avons pas besoin de prononcer
quelques paroles de bienvenue
vous connaissez le sujet la stabilité
internationale et cyber sécurité
conflits régionaux les relations
commerciales
nous avons abordé notre coopération en
haptique je vous en prie vos questions
pourriez vous nous parler des sujets
évoqués en détail aujourd'hui notamment
le cren là quel contexte avez vous
discuté de l'ukraine de la situation
dans les deux bases de la possibilité de
l'adhésion de l'ukraine le temps et il y
avait de grandes attentes relatives au
retour des impasses adore par exemple
monsieur ou shakhova dit que ce serait
possible
merci oui concernant le retour des
ambassadeurs à leur place habituelle de
travail à moscou et à washington
nous nous sommes convenus que cette
question est résolue
les ambassadeurs seront de retour dans
leurs ambassadeurs respectifs demain ou
après demain c'est une question
technique nous nous sommes convenus
également que le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères et le département
d'état américain vont entamer des
consultations sur l'ensemble de notre
interaction dans les relations
diplomatiques pour déblayer tous les
problèmes j'ai eu l'impression que les
deux parties vont essayer de trouver des
solutions concernant l'ukraine hui nous
avons abordé ce sujet je ne peux pas
dire que très en détail mais j'ai
compris que le président baden est
d'accord que la base de ce règlement en
ukraine dans l'est de l'ukraine par par
les discussions nous avons abordé
quelques détails également du retour de
l'ukraine vers l'automne et tartas s'il
vous plaît
vous avez dit que l'un des sujets
simples et la stabilité stratégique à
pourriez vous parler un peu plus en
détail des décisions dans ce domaine ça
frisait la russie les etats-unis
vont-ils reprendre relancer les
négociations concernant la seule visée
stratégique et le désarmement
s'agit-il de l'application des traités
ou la signature d'un nouvel accord les
états unis et la fédération de russie
assume une responsabilité particulière
pour la stabilité stratégique dans le
monde
nous sommes les deux grandes puissances
nucléaires de par le nombre de têtes et
de vecteurs et de par le niveau et le
niveau moderne des armes que nous
possédons nous assumons cette
responsabilité et je crois que tout le
monde comprend que le président wade n a
pris une décision responsable qui
concerne la prolongation de l'accord a
new start
bien sûr la question se pose qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire ensuite
nos sommes convenus de la poursuite des
consultations au niveau des ministères
sous l'égide du département d'état et du
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
au niveau de travail nous avons décidé
de
nous convenir sur le personnel de ces
négociations mais toute chance ici annan
a donné la parole à tout d'abord les en
général de cette réunion s'est déroulée
de manière constructive
où est-il la deuxième question 1
concernant les huiles vers attaque avez
vous évoqué cette question avez vous
pris un engagement dans le domaine de
l'évaluation général j'estime qu'il n'y
a eu pas d'hostilité
oui bien sûr les discussions revêtaient
la nature assez principale il ya des
divergences dans nos évaluations mais
des deux parties nous avons fait preuve
de la volonté de nous comprendre et de
chercher les points de convergence ce
dialogue était assez constructif
concernant la cybersécurité nous nous
sommes convenus du fait que nous allons
commencer des consultations à mon avis
c'est très important
concernant la responsabilité assumée
je vous informe ce sont les choses qui
sont évidentes est connu pour le grand
public les sources américaines
je crains de confondre peut-être leur
appellation et leur nom donc les sources
et américaines estiment que la grande le
grand nombre la majeure partie des cyber
attaques viennent du territoire
américain
deuxième place revient au canada ensuite
deux pays de l'amérique latine et la
grande bretagne concernant le territoire
russe qui est l'origine des
cyberattaques ne figure pas dans cette
liste
ça c'est la première chose deuxième
chose au cours de 2020 nous avons reçu
dix demandes de la part de la partie
américaine qui concernait les cyber
attaques comme quoi les sites américains
ont été attaqués depuis le territoire
russe et de demandes cette année si nous
avons donné des réponses adressées à des
collègues américains de sa part la
partie russe a dépêché cinq demandes et
cette année 6,35 demande mais pour le
moment nous n'avons aucune réponse
il y a donc du pain sur la planche et la
question qui devrait assumer cette
responsabilité
c'est la question des négociations sont
va entamer ses consultations et nos
estimant que ce secteur de cyber
sécurité est très important partout dans
le monde pour les états unis en
particulier et pour la fédération de
russie également par exemple nos
savons qu'il ya eu des cyber attaques
dirigées contre une société et gazière
aux états unis et qui a dû payer à des
personnes qui ont fait chanter cette
entreprise 5 millions de dollars une
partie de cette somme a été remboursée
mais la russie n'y est pour rien nous
sommes confrontés également assez menace
par exemple le système de santé public
d'une région d'une région russe a été
cible de ces attaques
et ce travail et est coordonné depuis le
territoire américain
je ne pense pas que les autorités
américaines ont quelques intérêts dans
ces attaques
il faut donc abandonné toutes sortes d'
intox
au niveau d'experts nous avons besoin de
travailler dans les intérêts des états
unis et de la fédération de russie qui
est nos sommes convenus et nous y sommes
prêts la chaîne arte les micros s'il
vous plaît prenez le micro de revenir
sur ma question la deuxième partie de ma
question avez-vous pris des engagements
pour mettre fin aux menaces adressée à
la reine à vous savez qu'il y a eu des
exercices militaires
la fédération de russie à la deuxième
partie de ma question avez vous pris l
engagement de mettre fin aux attaques
contre l'opposition
je n'ai pas entendu cette partie de
questions peut-être ce n'étaient pas
traduits
concernant dans un engagement vis-à-vis
de l'ukraine
nous avons un seul engagement contribuer
à la réalisation des accords de mise
comme si que la partie ukrainienne est
prête à le faire on va entamer cette
voie sans aucun doute je porte votre
intervention sur le fait que novembre
dernier la délégation ukrainienne nous a
adressé ses estimations sur st leur
vision des accords de minsk
il parle de l'intégration politique du
temps basse dans le système politique
ukrainien et dans la constitution
ukrainienne a donc il faut apporter des
amendements à la constitution
ukrainienne
et deuxième chose c'est que les
frontières entre la russie et l'ukraine
qui passe par le donbass vont être
occupés par les gardes-frontières ils
craignent un bon lendemain des élections
ukrainiennes qu'est-ce que l'ukraine
propose donc le premier pas c'est de
faire rentrer les tropiques reviennent
vers leur base habituelle c'est-à-dire
entrer dans le donbass ensuite fermer
les frontières et troisième chose tenir
les élections
trois mois après ces deux démarches
auront on n'a pas besoin d'être juriste
pour comprendre que c'est contraire aux
accords de minsk
et je pense que la réponse était la
russie est évidente concernant les
exercices militaires ces exercices ont
lieu sur notre propre territoire à
l'instar des états unis qui font leurs
exercices militaires sur leur propre
territoire
[Musique]
malheureusement nos amis américains le
fond près des frontières russes
donc c'est la partie russe qui est
préoccupé par ces agissements des
troupes américaines mais c'est aussi un
sujet des négociations concernant notre
composition russe et le citoyen dont
vous parlez est la première chose cette
personne savait qu'ils aient des roches
aux lois qui sont en vigueur en russie
puisque il était condamné par sursis et
donc ils ont il a ignoré ces exigences
des lois il est parti dans un autre pays
et une fois de retour de l'hôpital
et quand il a mis en ligne ces vidéos
sur internet
alors cette loi devrait être respectée
et donc il était recherché
il était de retour en russie il est et
je crois qu'il avait pris conscience
qu'il serait
interpellée alors concernant ces
personnes comme celui ci concernant
toutes les personnes et qui sont opposés
à aux autorités russes pour le moment si
le format de cette conférence de presse
ne permet pas de le dire en détail mais
je veux vous dire très simplement et
vous allez comprendre et vous pouvez en
informer votre public
les etats unis d'amérique
on est en hausse et que la russie est
l'adversaire l'ennemi des états unis le
concret le fait en deux en 2017
la législation américaine contient des
dispositions qu'on croit les états unis
devraient soutenir la démocratie en
russie et les organisations politiques
en russie
c'est la loi américaine qui le dit alors
on se pose la question si le récit c'est
l'ennemi quels sont les organisations
politiques vont être soutenus par les
états unis sur le territoire us je pense
que ce ne sont pas les organisations
politiques et qui renforce la fédération
de russie mais qui contiennent la russie
ça c'est la déclaration officielle
c'est l'objectif des états unis ce sont
les organisations et les personnes qui
contribuent à la politique américaine
est sur le territoire russe
comment réagir donc de notre côté et je
crois que on comprend très bien que nous
devrions être méfiant mais réagir dans
le contexte de la loi russe
la parole la parole à robin s'il vous
plaît pas mais la robine l'agencé getty
cas je voudrais poursuivre ce sujet les
etats-unis parlent toujours des
prisonniers politiques
un prétendu un peu psy mais le sujet de
nos colonies at-il été évoqué lors de
vos négociations et de quelle manière
est une autre question importante
nous voyons qu'il ya une nouvelle étape
des relations russo américaines qui a
commencé au début de la présidence du
président baden 1
c'est à dire que le président ben ali a
abordé le sujet des droits de l'homme et
des personnes qui sont liées à cette
question en la fédération aussi nous en
avons parlé à son initiative ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point sur les
déclarations fracassantes tout le monde
français ensuite le président baden
avait appelé on s'est expliqué son
explication m'a satisfait il a proposé
de se retrouver c'est son initiative
nous nous sommes retrouvés et encore une
fois cette conversation a été donc ce
genre de discussion doit avoir tous les
dirigeants entre quatre yeux
ensuite comme ça les accusations son
prédécesseur et donc le président nike a
décidé de répondre de cette façon vous
savez emprunt c'est ce qui se produit
dans nos pays d'une façon ou d'une autre
engage la responsabilité de la direction
politique et je les premières personnes
de l'état six responsables qui
regardaient dans les rues aux états unis
tous les jours il ya des marques et
notamment de dirigeants d'organisations
politiques coince les gens on les tue je
me rappelle justement d'altacom savent
où une femme sort d'une voiture elle se
fait assassiner tout de suite d'une
balle dans le dos prenons l'afghanistan
d'un coût de 120 personnes assassinées
en pleine hausse par exemple supposons
que ce soit une erreur ça arrive les
erreurs mais les enquêtes faites à
montrer que les tirs menés depuis des
drones et des hélicoptères avaient
directement visé des civils qui porte la
responsabilité qui assume la
responsabilité de c2c de ces crimes
en ce qui concerne des droits de l'homme
continue à travailler
il ya des choses qui ne respectent ni
les lois américaines ni les principes
des droits de l'homme il ya guantanamo
il ya les prisons de la cia ou les
tortures ont été appliquées et ça c'est
quoi ces les droits de l'homme peut-être
je pense que non est ce que quelqu'un
ici dans la salle sera est prêt à dire
que c'est la défense des droits de
l'homme ces prisons donc c'est la
politique
vl et nous partons de la pratique
nous considérons que de telles choses
existent et donc nous nous adaptons
notre position et donc les gens qui
reçoivent de l'argent de l'étranger pour
défendre les intérêts de ceux qui les
paient doivent assumer leurs
responsabilités
la chaîne arte castillet j'ai une
question sur l'arctique
vous avez dit que je vous avais évoqué
ce sujet les états unis et depuis
longtemps et que c'est leur vie
et une militarisation de l'arctique et
ses alliés et leurs alliés par exemple
récemment le secrétaire blinken a dit à
exprimer à metz préoccupation par les
actes des médias russes on a fait
effectivement nous avons abordé ce thème
dans la réunion élargie et en détail
c'est un sujet important et concernant
l'article d'une manière générale et en
particulier de l'itinéraire du nord nous
avons parlé parce que c'est une question
régionale c'est une question économique
important de cette préoccupation de la
partie américaine un très beau de la
militarisation ne repose sur absolument
rien je nous ne faisons rien de ce qui
avait été fait par exemple en os tout
simplement nous resterons les
infrastructures de l'époque il ya des
infrastructures militaires il ya des
infrastructures de la garde de la
surveillance des frontières il n'y avait
rien en matière de protection de
l'environnement et là nous mettons en
place de nouvelles infrastructures là
c'est important il ya des structures de
sauvetage si quelqu'un est en péril en
mer par exemple et j'ai dit à nos
collègues que je ne vois ici aucun motif
de préoccupation et que au contraire je
pense que nous pouvons travailler nous
devons travailler ensemble la russie les
états-unis sont font partie des huit
pays membres du conseil de l'arctique et
cette année la russie assume la
présidence de ce conseil de l'arctique
par exemple vous savez que entre
l'alaska et la tchoukotka yann le
célèbre de détroit de béring d'un côté
c'est la russie de l'autre côté c'est
les états unis et cela fait que nous
devons unir nos efforts
en ce qui concerne l'utilisation de
l'itinéraire du grand nord elle doit
répondre aux 2 ac c'est à dire l'acte
sur la navigation méritiez maritime et
le code arctique qui se compose de
différents textes ratifiés en 2017
j'ai attiré l'attention de nos
partenaires sur le fait que nous la
russie
nous avons l'intention de nous en tenir
pleinement aux normes du droit
international
nous n'avons jamais rien enfreint nous
sommes prêts à coopérer avec tous les
pays et toutes les entreprises qui
travaillent à la conquête de grand nord
par exemple il ya les questions de
navigation ce qu'il dure six mois et je
suis de l'année et avec le réchauffement
climatique ça devrait s'étendre à
l'ensemble de l'année et donc il ya
notamment des brise-glaces atomique
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont usés et donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya une demande si nous
en construisons aujourd'hui ce qu'il ya
une demande et le droit maritime
international fait qu' il stipule leur
régime des eaux internationales
notamment les eaux interne
les maires interne les eaux
territoriales les eaux limitrophes
les zone économique franche et la hotte
mary c'est à dire les maires interne ce
son qui se trouve à l'intérieur d'un
territoire national il ya les eaux
territoriales à 12000 du littoral et les
pays sur les mers intérieures
doivent assurer un passage libre y
compris pour les navires militaires
en ce qui concerne les mers intérieures
il y a là un régime particulier les pays
ne sont pas obligés de fournir des
documents ou des droits particuliers
si je me souviens bien ya cinq maires
concernés ici par exemple celle d'il ya
le le détroit de l'homme tout ça
représente 965 mine de littoral mais
c'est notre droit souverain de laisser
passer ou de ne pas laisser passer mais
nous n'habitons pas de ce droit nous
faut ni sont un droit d'accès il ya eu
des demandes de passage l'an dernier et
dont l'essentiel c'était des bateaux
battant pavillon russe et nos services
de contrôle se réfère au code article
qui lui même défini clairement les
exigences pour chaque catégorie de
navires et nous travaillons avec
l'ensemble des pays qui peuvent être
concernées et nous allons travailler
ensemble pour résoudre toutes les
questions pas sur des questions qui ont
besoin encore de résolution mais je suis
convaincu que nous trouverons des
solutions
je ne vois aucun problème ici qui ne
puisse être résolu
la chaîne ntv
radanne alors la parole bonjour monsieur
poutine devant relation ou de relations
normales entre la russie et les etats
unis ont toujours été le gage de la
stabilité globale et mettant les
relations sont-elles
que vous avez dit baden à partager votre
avis maintenant vous dites qu'il ya des
lignes rouges pour la russie on voit que
les américains ont aussi leurs lignes
rouges
est ce que vous avez réussi convenir
cette décision de ne pas franchir ces
lignes rouges je peux vous dire que dans
l'ensemble nous comprenons de quoi nous
n'ont pas nos partenaires américains ils
comprennent de quoi nous parlons quand
il s'agit des lignes rouges
mais je vous dis franchement aller loin
en détail sur ses lignes rouges
non là on n'a pas encore été à ce
moment-là ce que je veux dire c'est que
nous sommes mis d'accord pour travailler
en matière de cybersécurité de stabilité
stratégique et au cours de ces
consultations
de même que niveau de l'article par
exemple il doit y avoir dans des
discussions et je pense que nous
parviendrons à des accords maintenant et
bisenius nos collègues américains à vos
la parole merci beaucoup monsieur le
président joe biden dit à maintes
reprises qu'il allait répondre à des
cyberattaques en provenance de la russie
qu'est-ce qui a dit précisément des
ménages peut être qu est-ce que les
etats-unis vont-ils faire c'est la
russie ne cesse pas c'est cyberattaque
est une autre question relative à alexeï
navalni sont fondues anti corruption a
été qualifiée d' assassin extrémistes et
tous les participants ne peuvent pas
être et le pourquoi avez vous peur de
cela encore une fois je respecte ce que
je répète ce que j'ai déjà dit
sur à propos des agents de l'étranger et
des gens qui se positionne comme
opposition systématique j'ai répondu
déjà à votre collègue c'est cnn c'est ça
admettons je pense que c'est une loi de
jean c'est guérir qu'il faut répondre
aussi à votre question donc je répète
encore une fois les ils ont dit qu'ils
allaient soutenir certaines
organisations politiques en russie
en même temps ils ont déclaré que la
fédération de russie était l'ennemi et
qu'il ferait en sorte de contenir le
développement de la question quels sont
les organisations politiques de la
communauté internationale et des états
unis qui doivent soutenir ces
organisations d'opposition et les
financer déjà dans les années 30
les états unis avaient qualifié
certaines organisations d'argent de
l'étranger et cette déclaration
d'organes organisation étrangère
continue travail et des organisations
écrit extremis là c'est autre chose et
les organisations dont 20 par les ont
appelé ouvertement à faire des
manifestations de masse des désordres de
masse en russie impliquer des mineurs et
ça c'est interdit par la loi russe
ils ont donné des instructions comment
préparer des cocktails molotov par
exemple les utiliser contre les forces
de l'ordre et ils ont publié des données
depuis les états unis on était confronté
récemment des événements graves après
le meurtre d'un afro-américain leur
dernier donc il ya eu tout un mouvement
hellemmes qui s'est mis en place
je vais pas commenter simplement ce que
je veux dire c'est que ce que nous avons
vu c'est sa cage ces infractions à la
loi etc etc
nous notre compassion envers les
américains mais nous ne voulons pas
qu'une telle chose se produise dans
notre pays et nous ferons tout pour
empêcher que cela se produise ici c'est
pas une question de craindre de ne pas
craindre donné le micro
s'il vous plaît mais vous n'avez pas
répondu et méchant tu ne regardes et
l'ensemble de vos aux adversaires
politiques sont soit tués soit envoyée
en prison
n'est ce pas signale qu'elle n'a pas
besoin de tes côtés tu fais quelques os
emprisonné quelqu'un ces personnes sont
entrés dans le concret américain avec
des rebondissements à gogo
revendications politiques
il y a quatre cents personnes qui sont
menacées par la prison jusqu'à 20 au 25
ans qui sont déclarés terroriste interne
ils sont ok accusé par des crimes et
autres crimes
soixante dix ont été interpellés tout de
suite et 30 parmi eux sont toujours dans
la prison
pour quelle raison on ne comprend pas
très bien puisque les autorités des
états ne nous informe pas et quelques
personnes ont été tuées une femme a été
directement et fut tué par balles et par
un policier donc ça se passe dans de
nombreux pays et je souligne encore une
fois il ya de la compassion de notre
part
en auvergne les américains mais nous ne
voulons pas que ça se passe en russie
encore à quelques questions
la roue les vestiaires avaient réussi à
parvenir à un accord avec les américains
sur le retour des russes a impressionné
aux états unis oui nous en avons parlé
le président wade n a soulevé cette
question
il a parlé des prisonniers américains
qui se trouvent dans les prisons russes
nous en avons parlé et nous pouvons
trouver un compromis le ministre russe
des affaires étrangères et le
département d'état et vont travailler
est une question de la chaîne rossia
bonjour mikhail antonov
la chaîne rossia vous avez dit que vous
avez évoqué le commerce avec le
président baden as les milieux
d'affaires à des débits sont intéressés
par le développement qui sont les
perspectives selon vous cela ne dépend
pas de nous cela dépend de la partie
américaine non ne déclarant aucune
sanction et restrictions après
l'arrivée de ces restrictions dans le
commerce les états unis ont perdu autant
que la russie bien sûr cela a eu un
impact sur notre développement en partie
et les etats unis ont en quelque sorte
contenu la russie mais il y a rien de
critique là dessus c'est la première
chose à deuxième chose cela concerne
l'intérêt des entreprises américaines
200 personnes ont été présents au forum
économique de saint-pétersbourg
c'était la plus grande des lego
délégations étrangères et suite à des
restrictions pour les entreprises
américaines certaines entreprises
américaines honte donc laisser
abandonner le marché russe à quoi ça
sert il n'y a aucun sasseville sens
puisque il n'y a que des parts
nos échanges commerciaux s'élève à 28
milliards de dollars
et durant le premier trimestre trimestre
et et l'inconnu la hausse de 16 5% et on
en a parlé
quelques questions de ceux de ce côté et
de l'autre côté show sans prix c'est la
jeune fille qui va poser la question
merci beaucoup monsieur le président un
pour cette opportunité de vous poser la
question le président baden à l'époque
l'état vice président il l' a dit qu' il
l'a vous à regarder
oui dans les yeux et l'a pas vu dames et
vous avez répondu cela veut dire que
nous nous entendons bien vous avez à
regarder directement dans ses yeux
qu'est ce que vous avez vu dans ses yeux
avez vous vu quelqu'un avec qui vous
pourriez conférer et dit monsieur le
club le président bak den est ce qu'il
vous a invité à venir à la maison
blanche le président bédié ne m'a pas
évités et chez lui pour le moment je
n'ai pas n'a pas adressé cette
invitation au président américain que ce
que je crois que il y à des
circonstances et qui doivent être
réunies pour ces visites
concernant ne regarder dans les yeux
pour voir l'âme de cette personne je
l'entends non pas pour la première fois
puis je suis parce que ça peut arriver
mais si vous me demandez mon avis sur le
président baden davies
je crois que c'est une personne pondéré
constructive très expérimenté ça se voit
tout de suite il est s'est souvenu de sa
famille un peu il a parlé un peu de des
paroles de sa mère ce sont des choses
à première vue qui ne sont pas
importantes mais cela montre que c'est
une personne de qualité
cela montre ses qualités morales et cela
provoque de la sympathie jeu j'ai un peu
l'impression que qu'on a abordé le même
langage et nous n'avons pas besoin de
regarder dans les yeux
nous protégeons les intérêts de de nos
nations de nos peuples et c'est très
pratique entrée jose au prix kolesnikov
commerçante
monsieur poutine quand même à l'issue de
ce sommet avez-vous de nouvelles
illusions
je n'ai aucune illusion ancien même
pourquoi par les désillusions
non je n'ai pas dit lui d'illusions ce
n'est pas le cas encore une question
allez-y vous avez le micro
[Musique]
vous évoquez le sujet des changements
climatiques et la deuxième question
concernant les médias américains
heureusement vous avez accordé une
grande interview à nbc
vous croyez que c'est juste que vous
accordez une interview aux médias
américains alors que les présidents
américains d'accor pas d'interviews aux
médias et selon vous est ce que ces
interviews en un pas positive mais
concernant certaines attaques
je veux dire que c'est la pratique et
des relations internationales
aujourd'hui rien à faire j'y suis
habitué on vit avec depuis des décennies
concernant les interviews cela est
décidée par des responsables d'un pays
concret si un dirigeant veut parler à
une autre nation on essaie de le faire
et mes interviews à la presse américaine
ont cet objectif concernant les
activités de nos médias les médias
russes
en général le président pas eden a parlé
de l'activité de la chaîne liberté ou
bien europe libre en russie qui était
déclarée à jambles étrangers en russie
j'ai l'impression que les membres de la
délégation américaine ne connaissent pas
très bien cette chaîne
mais je parle de licha surtout des yéyés
et s'écoute nick qui ont été privé
d'accréditation et c'était la mesure de
rotation de la part de la russie tandis
que le château day rempli de toutes les
exigences des autorités américaines sur
le territoire américain
quoique il y à toutes sortes d'obstacles
de nature financière par exemple nous
n'avons pas cette sorte de problèmes et
les médias américaines ne respecte
pleinement les exigences et historien
russe quand même mais j'espère qu'on va
réussir grâce à notre ministère des
affaires étrangères de le faire dahlin à
paulhan sky à la chaîne euronews
nous avons vu que vous avez serré la
main chang hayden début de votre réunion
estimez-vous que à cette étape là et les
réalistes de à passer une nouvelle étape
des relations des relations claires et
transparentes
ce qu'est que les deux partis chercher
côté léon tolstoï disait que dans la vie
il n'ya pas de bonheur y'a que des
clercs et qui sont très précieux
justement dans cette situation on peut
parler de la confiance en famille mais
il y a des indices des éclairs qui ont
été manifestées et c'est bien je vous en
prie vous avez le micro vous voulez le
deuxième micro ivan drago est la chaîne
pervyi kanal le sujet de couronnes et
virus c'est un des sujets clés partout
dans le monde avait voulu évoquer ce
sujet
lors du sommet avec le président
américain dans le pire on dit quelles
sont les perspectives de coopération
avec les états unis afin de vaincre le
virus a peut-être s'agit-il de la
reconnaissance des vaccins oui nous
avons évoqué le sujet très en bref comme
vous le savez même sous l'administration
précédente américaine nous avons réagi à
la demande de la partie américaine
nous avons envoyé le matériel médical
pour aider les états unis d'amérique
8 les etats unis c'est un pays puissant
mais mais qu'ils avaient besoin des
respirateurs et on l'a envoyée
gratuitement et nous sommes prêts à la
coopération dans ce secteur mais
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas parlé en
détail de ce sujet avec avec le
président thein qu'on a vu une
détérioration
après votre sommeil est un des facteurs
qui permettent de d'espérer que cela ces
situations ne se répétera pas on a déjà
touché les fonds non difficile de vous
répondre
toutes les actions qui ont été
manifestées par le congrès américain je
ne sais pas qu'est ce que le congrès
américain va inventer encore je ne sais
pas je vous en prie alexandre guillaume
comme sk pravda je ne sais pas si vous
êtes au courant ou non
quel est le résultat du sommet entre
vous et monsieur ben laden est la
deuxième question les américains avant
de venir à gênés à me disais qu'il
allait faire pression sur la russie vous
personnellement avez-vous ressenti cette
pression et comment avez-vous fait face
à cette pression est là qui sont clés
qui est je crois être intéressant pour
l'heure aussi
et qu'est-ce que vous monsieur poutine a
fait à genève et je pense que je pense
que c'est sus les gens dépensent aussi
aucune pression je n'ai pas ressenti
aucune pression
nous n'avons pas abordé d'autres sujets
qui ont été prévus et des deux parties
il n'y a aucune pression c'est pas
l'objectif de notre rencontre et quel
était le score de notre rencontre avant
notre rencontre le président à baden
disait que ce n'est pas une compétition
sportive et je suis d'accord avec lui
non il n'y a aucun score ce dialogue
était assez méticuleux concret détaillé
et qui se passait en ambiance qui est
donné l'espérance d'obtenir des
résultats
bbc news ce jose un prix qui signe ce
récit à l'accident ce qu'on croit que à
l'imprévisibilité c'est
les traits caractéristiques pour la
politique extérieure de la russie
êtes vous prêt à abandonner cette
imprévisibilité dans votre politique
pour améliorer les relations mais vous
savez mélangez tout et vous avez
beaucoup réussi je vous envie
pour répondre la première partie de
votre question vous dites quant à
l'occident on dit que la politique russe
est imprévisible
alors je vous renvoie le ballon par
exemple l'accord abm a c'est un accord
très prévisible pourquoi le détruire
pourquoi sortir de l'accord inf
est ce que c'est de la stabilité la
sortie de l'accord consacré au ciel
ouvert presque rien ne reste dieu merci
le président biden a décidé de prolonger
le traité new start c'était très
raisonnable pour les cinq ans à venir
si on parle de l'ukraine il ya eu un
coup d'état en ukraine le président
ianoukovitch a accepté toutes les
revendications de l'opposition
et il était prête à parts à partir mais
il a fallu deux organiser un coup d'état
en ukraine
et vous croyez que nous sommes
imprévisibles non je ne le pense pas à
mon avis nous sommes à digoin et nos
réagissons aux menaces qui se présente
et je crois que pour prendre la
situation stable il faut parler des
règles de conduite c'est la stabilité
internationale c'est la cybersécurité ce
sont les questions des conflits
régionaux et je crois que ce sont les
sujets qui peuvent être obligé des
négociations et qui peuvent donner des
résultats
merci
on va bientôt chanter des chansons là je
comprends pas très bien
vos collègues étrangers allaient donnant
la parole à quelqu'un parmi les
étrangers a lésé bloomberg
la dernière question le maire tenus çà
et là arkhipova mais ce putin en 2016
après le sommet avec trempe de nouvelles
sanctions américaines et est rapidement
imposé aujourd'hui lors des négociations
avec vos reçu des assurances de monsieur
ben laden que les états unis ne vont pas
imposer de nouvelles sanctions
et quant aux résultats que vous avez
évoqué qu'il y a des désespoirs qu'il ya
surtout de confiance
avez-vous du point de vue de visibilité
des accords qui existent avez-vous
maintenant plus de confiance estimez
vous qu'il est le faire a effectivement
parce que je crois que maintenant les
toutes les institutions se tiennent aux
états unis la politique de daybyday ne
garde plus de solidarité et quant aux
consultations sur les craintes par
exemple où la cybersécurité donc des
groupes de travail seront
créer c'est ça et avez vous marquez des
rouges
ensuite nous sommes cellino j'ai déjà
dit à plusieurs reprises
cette compréhension
elle apparaît quand on discute sur les
principaux axes de discussion c'est pas
la peine de se frayer des uns des autres
si les gens se rencontrent pour discuter
c'est pas ça qu'il faut faire sinon ça
sert à rien de se voir en ce qui
concerne les sanctions oui y ait des
restrictions sur le plan économique j'ai
déjà dit nous connaissons les humeurs
politiques en interne aux états unis
mais nous ne pouvons pas comprendre tout
ce qui se passe là bas donc il y à des
adversaires au développement des
relations avec les états unis
il yad'autres des partisans aussi c'est
difficile de dire qui
et plus important ici mais si après
notre rencontre des mesures centre
entreprises notamment sur ce que vous
avez évoqué après 2016
ça veut dire que ce serait à nouveau une
opportunité manquée maintenant c'est
effectivement la dernière question un
journaliste canadienne à nous seuls
présidents un merci beaucoup
tam a réitéré ce qu'offre la radio
canada vous avez dit à mes collègues que
vous attendez là interprétation
l'interprétation
je sais pas quelle chaîne branches et là
j'ai pas de traduction 1 2 3 il faut
trouver la bonne chaîne j'entends rien
je suis attendez attendez une seconde
excusez moi donc le son c'est bon
répéter s'il vous plaît la radio canada
à moscou vous avez dit à mes collègues
avoue rick des questions aux nets soit
posée j'ai une question qui a été posée
par ma fille qui a 9 ans elle m'a
demandé c'est quoi que ce soit mais
pourquoi se met tellement important
qu'elle soit votre réponse à une fille
âgée de 9 ans pourquoi les relations
entre la russie les états sont tellement
compliqués moi aussi je voudrais le
savoir pourquoi le jeune ne peuvent pas
participer à des protestations
oui c'est bien que votre fille qui a 9
ans s'intéresse à ces questions la
réponse est simple il faut il faut dit à
votre enfant à regarder comme le monde
comme il est beau tout le monde est beau
et les dirigeants de ces deux pays qui
sont les deux plus grandes puissances
interne à son compte pour que le monde
soit plus sûre plus fiables soient
connaissent une plus grande prospérité
pour l'ensemble des habitants de notre
planète ils vont parler de questions qui
sont liées à des armes qui sont
terribles et qu'il faut limiter et pour
lesquels il faut élaborer des règles
communes qui vont parler de la
protection de l'environnement les
rivières pour que les mères support pour
qu'il n'y ait pas d'inondations qu'il
n'y ait pas de sécheresse qu'il y ait
suffisamment de denrées alimentaires
pour l'ensemble de la population de la
terre
ils vont parler de questions de santé
publique pour que justement les enfants
vont grandir pour qu'ils ne soient pas
malades pour qu'ils puissent aller à
l'école et qu'ils puissent avoir la
conscience sur en regardant vers
l'avenir et je suis mesdames messieurs
je suis sûr que vous avez couvert cet
événement précisément dans cette optique
je vous remercie pour votre attention
bonne soirée à tous